so here's Jen congratulating kite on
finding him or so it would seem
in actuality this is jinx mashing that
subscribe button for the new old review
which was rather oddly at that very
moment placed on the face of our dear
kite resulting in Jing receiving regular
Hunt onto content uploaded straight in T
as YouTube feed but also resulting in
kite being taken to hospital hello and
welcome to the new old review source for
everything anime and manga and today we
are diving back into the realm of Reddit
because I am being consistently amazed
by the kind of stuff that hunter and
fans create and post on a daily basis
and I am astounded that there is such a
strong online community for a series
that frequently takes these giga level
hiatuses but the pure love for hunter
hunter is still there and so we are
going to showcase it and today we are
going to start off by showing off some
quarantine craft where the user who has
chosen to correct kites crazy sock clown
as well as a PR part of knuckles taka
variability and these look absolutely
adorable and it's so interesting to see
that they've chosen number three on
crazy slots but you're going into kite
is a good number and it ended up being
the mysterious mace which we never
really got to delve into and perfectly
honestly I don't think we ever will
learn exactly how it works but assumedly
I guess does nothing to do with his
funky reincarnation and as for API I
love it
although I can't help but feel the need
to see a little felt IRS now alongside
him next up we have Hisoka featuring as
part of someone's college graduation and
congratulations to whoever that is
because I believe that it was not the
reddit post of themselves however this
person very clearly understands what
they are getting themselves into as
College does indeed possess both the
qualities of diplomas and debt and yes I
think it's pretty confirmed by now that
College is probably the worst an ability
ever created well actually I guess that
depends on where in the world you live
if your particular country based
university and ability doesn't have the
debt condition attached or it has it
attached at a much lower level then I
can imagine this one being quite OB in
any case this whole picture just makes
me wish I'd thought of it when I
graduated know that I was even a fan of
Hunter hunter at the time but I guess
I'll put it on the list of things to do
once I achieved time travel alright
moving on and guys I have honestly never
wanted a pair of shoes more in my life
than I do right now and I'm not even a
huge fan of wearing white shoes I prefer
black but I would make a lifelong
exception for natural if only for the
potential ability to literally kick
someone with the 100 type Guan Yin
Bodhisattva plus a little cool detail
that I didn't
notice at first glance is that that
shoelaces are different also cool ones
for Guanyin are very nice matching gold
and I guess I should also say this is
not the only pair of custom Hunter
hunter shoes that I saw on the old
reddit is there another one featuring
crop acara nouveau gain nose also one
with P tone kite both of which I also
feel a profound need for so I think this
next image very much speaks for itself
although the only thing it's saying is
an almighty Shuang and despite the fact
that this is very meme content it does
bring up an interesting idea being the
great tragedy that is Hisoka I mean he
spent so so much time in the series
cultivating gone into a more powerful
individual a fridge that he intended to
pick however during harvest season which
turned out to be the Chimera and talked
Hisoka was missing the one major arc in
which he does not make an appearance in
and it really does make me wonder how he
would have reacted like being turned on
by power is one thing but a Dahlgren is
just out of this world maybe it would
have even have sent a sliver of fear
into the strange clown man and I also
like to think about how he Sokka might
have reacted to marijuana as well who
would have been an even more terrifying
presence and speaking of whoever made
this image did so with the intention to
rip out my heart and just stomp it into
oblivion but that said it is pretty
funny though but my god I was not ready
when I witnessed the end of the Chimera
and talked for the first time it brought
legitimate tears to my eyes which is a
very difficult thing for any anime or
manga to do to me it was just so
painfully tragic and yet kind of perfect
moving in the complete opposite
direction we now on this we have this
this is wing on a chicken wing it was
now just known as chicken wing
specifically by my wife who actually
made this quote-unquote joke in her
series on the channel revealing hunt
hunter and in fact she actually wanted
me to photoshop his face on Twitch icahn
wing and I am so glad I couldn't be
bothered now because some other
questionable genius has gone and done it
for me alright now we have one of my
favorite things that I think I've ever
seen in my life which was made by cat
noodle this is a hunter hunter animal
crossing crossover and they need to say
right now that the entire video is
scored to departure but I can't play the
audio in this video because my ass will
get flagged so so hard but there is an
incredible amount of effort that has
been put into this which takes us on a
journey through the series really
there's a ton of recognizable scenes
like going cropper currently Oreo
encountering canary
gone and kill of our own greed island
with Biscay even marijuana and kimochi
pan gungi
bust The Phantom troop out perfection
and there's even the other iconic shot
if you soak a showering just for good
measure and I think I mentioned this
last time I don't even like animal
crossing but I love seeing it used as a
canvas for stuff like this
and I highly recommend that you go and
watch it would sound because that just
completes everything so there's a link
to the video in the pinned comment below
along with everything else so this is a
Hisoka makeup test and I wanted to
include it because it really does speak
volumes about what a powerful character
that Takashi has created here the fact
that even a gender bend makeup test can
install that same sense of alarming
enigma means that this character has the
ability to really transcend page and
screen of course it's also a really
great job by the cosplayer but you know
what there's just something about a star
and a tear tattoo that makes me want to
stay far far away which is perfect
I very much look forward to seeing the
full cosplay version so long as it's not
in a dark alleyway
now this post is entitled what is Fink's
doing at the election because yeah I
guess this background dudebro certainly
doesn't look like him although he's no
certainly isn't anywhere near as pointy
as mr. Fink's and the interesting thing
here is that there is precedent for
Phantom troop members being licensed
hunters I mean if we're looking beyond
Hisoka it was confirmed that Sherlock
was a hunter and really why not become
one you're all super overpowered figures
and that license can only help with your
various devious pots but yeah look this
is obviously not Fink's but he does
certainly have a hunter doppelganger out
there in the world alright more Hisoka
focus now because I guess that's just
what we do is hunt on defense though
this is pretty great we've got he's
soaked amusing about how hard it is to
find a real fight in this world and the
effort that he has gone to in order to
secure one then killer pops up and says
what about my father or grandfather both
they're crazy strong and you can just
hire them to kill you and then just a
little [ __ ] once again memes speaking
truth here they never really understood
why he soca wasn't smitten with
characters like silver and Zeno
especially considering how globally
renowned they are and also considering
his relationship with Allah me I mean I
wonder if there was a point where
someone becomes so strong that he soaked
his interest just fades away because in
the end I'm sure that he always wants
someone that he can overcome and yes as
a pun in that word overcome but he may
be looking for that in order to make
sure that he always moves on to the next
opponent giving himself as much of a
challenge as possible while still
remaining in relative comfort also upon
comfort and before anyone says it might
be an age thing Hisoka has all
so expressed interest in network
although I highly doubt he would have
known the extent of the Chairman's
abilities but yeah who do you think
would win either matchup Hisoka versus
Silva and Hisoka versus Eno now this is
a really fun post because look that's my
video and I really did not expect it to
see it plunked up on reddit but as
expected most people don't seem to care
whatsoever I mean look at that it has a
mere 18 up votes and a mighty singular
comment but still shout out to surf the
web 29 for potentially being a fan of
what I do here doctors hate him this man
was able to double his hair size and
girth with this one we had to trick and
you know what if I saw this piece of
targeted advertising then I would click
in an instant because there is nothing I
want more in this world than girthier
hair and you're telling me that all I
have to do to achieve such thing is to
make an anvil and despair fully cast my
life away for a few temporary moments of
glorious hair and really how could any
of us turn that down and just as a side
note I love the gun is also taking the
water divination test and I imagine that
that would very much be the results
because I'm pretty sure that the effect
is more pronounced depending on how
large the or exposure is parents eat
your food it's not that hot the food and
they have to say that this is the side
to back you know des that I have never
seen before and if anyone knows where I
could source such cards and please do
leave that information in the comments
below I am of course asking for a friend
but no not really I'm kind of a fiend
for cardboard and I love collecting all
sorts of we've related cards and I'd be
really keen to see the rest of the set
as well especially if it's the entirety
of the Phantom troop being portrayed in
this more casual setting like Phantom
troop beach trip I don't know why that's
one of the things I want most in this
world but it is so yeah if anybody knows
what these are called and where they are
and please do drop them in the comments
this post is entitled the ultimate pose
and whoa I don't think I've ever
realized just how common this pose is in
Hunter hunter in fact I'm certain that
this isn't even all of them in this
image because maybe I'm tripping but I
swear that marijuana does a similar pose
whenever he's playing gungi against
kimochi
and maybe even during his fight against
nature oh I'm pretty sure that was a
moment where maro I'm just sat down like
the boss he is but I'm less certain
about that one in any case this is a
serious power pose I really don't think
I've ever seen characters look more
threatening while sitting down
especially because they're not entirely
on guard either with the one leg opening
up in
exposing their arsh wings but I guess
that's just how much of a power pose it
is it's saying that's right I will leave
the most vulnerable part of my body open
to you because you have no chance of
reaching it anyway so this picture has a
long title and it goes a little
something like this this came to me in
the mail today because I ordered some
printed pictures online and I didn't
remember that I chose this photo
Hung's Inc the worst thing is that my
strict parents know who he soaked it is
and what he does and has just questioned
so so many questions why is of course
paramount but I'm also really keen to
know exactly what your parents reactions
were and how they know he Sokka like eye
appearances plain awesome and have they
watched hunter hunter or are they
particularly hyperaware of pedophilic
clowns in any case to each their own and
this is a lovely shot of you and your
assumed house bond oh now last time I
showed you all an image of silver zoldak
given the Sailor Moon redraw treatment
and this time around like father like
son I guess because it is Gila was done
and this is certainly one of the most
adorable assassins that I have ever seen
he looks strangely perfect as a Salus
count and I quite enjoy how irritable he
looks he likely is not enjoying this
experience and I wonder if this is Alec
is doing actually like maybe somebody
made a sneaky bizarre wish to nangka and
this for whatever reason was the result
gone I'm looking at you now for some
more quarantine creativity in him we
have the hunter Association logo cross
stitch style and this like everything
else I tend to see on this particular
subreddit is just fantastic and I can't
believe how inspired and creative hunt
hunt a fan seemed to be and just for
some comparison on that I did look into
various one-piece subreddits in the
hopes of doing a similar series on that
channel but there just wasn't this
quantity of creativity so hunda fans
really do seem to be something quite
special and finally for this edition I
present
popsicles Harry intriguingly detailed
popsicles mind you with one representing
Hisoka and the other one being crop
occur and look I don't know why this
exists but show it one why not
why not popsicle people and they look
really good actually and there were a
ton of just wonderful little minimalist
details that just make them however I
will say that I am not convinced on the
flavors of either of these because crop
ACCA's is probably very bitter and angry
Welles T sokka's would probably be far
too sweet for my tastes
but still fantastic work and fantastic
work to everyone
in this video but what do you guys think
please to leave your thoughts in the
comments below or even join my discord
server and if you came for some more
Hunter hunter content then please do go
and check out some of my other videos or
even subscribe to the channel for
regular Hunter hunter glory delivered
straight until YouTube feed but for now
this has been the new alt review and
I'll see you next time